foreign
[Applause]
and Meghan Markle make a trip to the
lake show he's loving California West
Coast lifestyle it suits him check out
the Duchess of Sussex native Angelino
and her hubby cozying up during a date
night at the Los Angeles Lakers game
against the Memphis Grizzlies
yeah Megan really gets into the game and
at one point the two pop up on the
Jumbotron much to their surprise
[Applause]
an eyewitness tells E.T the crowd was
cheering loudly for Megan and Harry in a
very positive way and they giggled when
they realized they were on the big
screen padding they seemed really happy
and were having a lot of fun they wanted
Independence they wanted Freedom they
didn't want to be restricted by Royal
protocol so if you look at what they've
now got they have got freedom uh
complete freedom to to really do what
they want to do they are showing that it
is working they're making it work for
them the couple's Courtside appearance
comes in the lead-up to the coronation
of Harry's father King Charles we are on
the eve of a coronation the most
important and momentous occasion in
Charles's life Buckingham Palace
revealed Harry's attending the May 6th
occasion without Megan and their two
kids Archie and lillibet some surprised
that Harry is going alone not so much
when you realize that it's his son
Archie's birthday the very same day so
Megan is in fact going to be staying
home in California to celebrate that
birthday which is perhaps quite
convenient given the tensions between
the two families right now and that
tension isn't going anywhere a royal
Insider tells E.T Prince William has no
interest in speaking to his brother
before their father's coronation I think
most people are optimistic that this
relationship will heal over time I just
don't believe that the coronation is
going to be the place for that to happen
our store says the Prince of Wales is
still a upset about Harry's Memoir spare
I have sources close to Prince William
who say that he is he's devastated but
he's also incredibly angry at the level
of detail which his brother has shared
in this book The King has made a real
point of extending an olive branch to
the couple and I think knowing just how
damaging this book was going to be for
the Royal Family
The Source says the relationship is
still fractured and it's unclear when
they'll mend fences William feels it was
a betrayal it's just too big of an event
it's too public there's going to be too
many people and too much going on but
hopefully it can be the start of some
real long-term healing
[Music]